fin
à
bonjour à tous je suis ses coûts et et
packtec l'union européenne j'imagine que
vous en entendez beaucoup parler ce sera
notre sujet cette semaine alors l'union
européenne c'est quoi qu'il fasse il une
coopération entre plusieurs pays en
europe ces pays réfléchissent ensemble
dans le but de se mettre d'accord sur
des règles que tout s'impliqueront mais
qui sont les pays de l'union européenne
voici une carte et de l'europe les pays
représentés en verre font partie de
l'union européenne à ce jour elle est
formée par 28 pays représentant plus de
508 millions d'habitants pourquoi ces
pays sera semble-t-il ainsi pierre au
trésor explique le fait de vouloir se
regrouper et de former cette union
l'économie est l'une des raisons
principales
par exemple développer des relations
avec d'autres pays permet de favoriser
les échanges de marchandises ou au corps
de se faire aider en cas de difficultés
après les deux grandes guerres mondiales
une mission essentielle de l'union
européenne a été de préserver la paix et
la sécurité de tous les pays européens
à ce titre l'union européenne a reçu le
prix nobel de la paix en 2002 1 quelle
est l'origine de l'union européenne les
six pays fondateurs de l'union
européenne sont la france le luxembourg
l'allemagne les pays-bas l'italie et la
belgique
ils sont à l'origine des bévues de
l'union européenne avec la coc à la
communauté européenne du charbon et de
l'acier la cec a favorisé les échanges
de matières premières nécessaires à la
sidérurgie afin d'accélérer la
reconstruction après guerre à la suite
lignon c'était la vie avec l'arrivée de
plusieurs nouveaux pays au sein de cette
communauté a grandit petit à petit
l'idée de l'union européenne qui dé
concrétiser en 1957
la création de la fée la communauté
économique européenne puis par l'union
européenne en 1993 donne moi un exemple
de décisions prises par l'union
européenne king des décisions prises par
le rap a été par exemple la création de
l'euro une monnaie unique utilisées par
18 pays faisant partie de cette union
afin de simplifier entre eux les
échanges commerciaux ces pays forment la
zone euro les dix autres pays de l'union
européenne ne font pas partie de cette
zone et la réunion dont l'union
européenne en tant que les départements
français d'outre-mer la réunion fait
partie de l'union européenne au sein de
laquelle elle constitue une région
ultrapériphérique c'est à dire qu'elle
se trouve en dehors du continent
européen l'union européenne est donc
riche en histoire et un rôle que portant
à bientôt dans notre approche à
l'épisode